[Applaus]
[Musik]
die islamische republik iran ist für
viele eines der geheimnisvollsten wende
im nahen osten und sogleich der erzfeind
des westens mit mehr als 80 millionen
einwohnern bevölkerungsmäßig so groß wie
deutschland und gemessen an der
landfläche eines der zwanzig größten
länder der welt ein land das also so
groß wie überraschend ist in der tat ist
es durchaus möglich dass sich das bild
dass du momentan von ihrer hass für
immer verändert haben wird wenn du auf
ende dieses videos angekommen sind denn
obwohl das ehemals blühende trainieren
seit jahrzehnten von einer starren elite
brutaler kleriker und radikal
fundamentalistischen juristen beherrscht
wird können wir bei genauerem hinsehen
unter dieser verkosteten schale von
machthabern ein völlig anderes land
entdecken sowohl gesellschaftlich als
auch wirtschaftlich ich würde sogar so
weit gehen zu behaupten dass wir ohne
die islamische revolution von 1979 heute
eine supermacht vor uns hätten
ein einflussreiches wohlhabendes und
entwickeltes land das die benachbarte
türkei
mit ziemlicher sicherheit vollkommen in
den schatten stellen würde
vielleicht wäre der iran sogar der beste
freund des westens der bfs der us- ok in
der gesamten region geworden und nein
ich übertreibe es nicht aber was er mir
nicht glaubt dann hört euch doch einfach
mal folgende fakten an
[Musik]
im jahr 1977 den letzten nennen wir
erstmal normalen jahr vor der
islamischen revolution war die iranische
wirtschaft und 26 prozent größer als die
der türkei um 65 prozent größer als
dieses koreas und fünfeinhalb mal so
groß wie die jungs in den sechziger
siebziger jahren erlebte das land einen
enormen wirtschaftlichen aufschwung ist
übertrag saudi arabien als erdöl
exportierende nation nummer eins zog
zahlreiche investitionen und viele
einwanderer an
auch aus europa es wurde zuerst
industriemacht im nahen osten seine
wirtschaft diversifizierte sich und die
regierung begann sogar mit dem bau eines
ganzen netzes von kernkraftwerken um das
land mit energie zu versorgen
heute jedoch hat sich das blatt gewendet
und zwar drastisch etwas 40 jahre nach
der islamischen revolution ist die
südkoreanische wirtschaft die ja mal so
groß und die türkische fast doppelt so
groß wie die iranische und pro kopf ist
die wirtschaft des damals total verbockt
namens bereits heute gleichauf mit den
iran und in der tat wir in dieser grafik
sehen könnt begann die iranischen
wirtschaft zu kollabieren als die
unruhen ausbrachen die zur islamischen
revolution führten und seither ganz der
44 jahre lang hat es das land nicht
geschafft wieder auf die beine zu kommen
[Musik]
so gab es zwei drei oder vier verlorene
generationen so bitter wie als die
totalitäre besagt ein großer teil
europas durch nazis und danach kommunist
natürlich lief auch davor während der
ära des schahs nicht alles für jeden
wurde hat richtig besonders in bezug auf
meinungsfreiheit
mit sicherheit kann man aber sagen dass
das was danach kam noch viel viel
schlimmer ist was genau war es aber was
die iranischen wirtschaft in den ruin
trieb nun die islamische revolution war
nicht nur eine gesellschaftliche
politische wende sondern wurde von einer
tiefgreifenden wirtschaftsreformen
begleitet die einen guten teil der
bestehenden privaten wirtschaft im land
einfach auslöschen
in der zeit des schahs der übrigens ein
lausiger manager war hätte der staat
viel einfluss und das wirtschaftsmodell
war stark kooperativ ausgerichtet aber
dennoch gab es eine aufstrebende mittel
und eine blühende unternehmer schicht
mit viel potenzial aber natürlich
spielte die revolution unter anderem
darauf ab alles los zu werden was er
denn die nach dem früheren regime also
war es offensichtlich dass etwas
drastisches getan werden musste
dieses etwas punkte sich als massive
verstaatlichungen und enteignungen das
neu erschienene ayatollahs beschloss
geben zu bestrafen der mit dem star oder
seinem inneren kreis geschäfte gemacht
hatte was zu einer massenflucht von
kapital und know-how führte ein prozess
der massiv verstärkt wurde durch den
blutigen krieg der 1980 zwischen saddam
husseins säkulären irak und dem iran dem
neuen gottesstaat ayatollahs ausdruck
irans junge unternehmer schicht verließ
das land in scharen um anderswo eine
bessere zukunft zu suchen
sehr viele junge talentierte und
intelligente person damals ist ausland
und kehrten nie wieder in ihre heimat
zurück sie wollten das nicht als
kanonenfutter dienen in einem sinnlosen
krieg verheizt werden der mehr als 600
tausend menschenleben kosten würde
und nein auch in den 40 jahren
islamischer herrschaft ist die viren
nicht gelungen eine neue generation
dynamischer geschäftsleute und
innovativer unternehmer zu erschaffen
schon komisch nicht wahr und glaubt mir
das liegt ganz bestimmt nicht nur daran
dass die usa seit der machtübernahme der
ayatollahs wirtschaftssanktionen
verhängt haben denn dem land fehlt so
ziemlich alles was unternehmer braucht
von rechtssicherheit keine spur
mal sehen wer ist in einem land zu
investieren in dem es keine andere
sicherheit
gibt als das wohlwollen der dollars und
der revolutionsgarden es scheint
sicherlich nicht die beste idee der welt
zu sein sich auf diese bieten im
mittelalter stecken gebliebenen älteren
herrn zu verlassen all das scheint nicht
nur zugang zu den internationalen
märkten 1 sein lässt auch die
vorhandenen ausländischen
direktinvestitionen im verhältnis zur
wirtschaftlichen und demographischen
größe des landes sowie im hinblick auf
die fülle natürlicher rohstoff vorkommen
wie ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
erscheinen das ergebnis es sanktionen
die von dort schon verhängt wurden war
zum beispiel ein rückgang des iranischen
produkt inlandsprodukts um sechs prozent
im jahr 2018 6,8 prozent im jahr 2019
und 2020 lassen wir mal außen vor weil
krone offensichtlich viel
schwerwiegendere auswirkungen hatte als
die sanktionen was bedeutet das aber nun
mit anderen worten wenn wir das
wirtschaftswachstum zwischen 2018 und 19
vorsichtigen haben die sanktionen dazu
geführt dass die iranische wirtschaft im
vergleich zur entwicklung der
weltwirtschaft mehr als 22 prozent
zurückgefallen ist das sind die wahren
kosten des sanktionen zu den iran
mehr als ein fünftel seiner
volkswirtschaft aber vergessen wir nicht
dass die sanktionen vielleicht ein
weiterer grund sind war unter ihr ahnung
da niederlegt aber sie sind nicht der
hauptgrund die wahre ursache der
probleme in denen das land seit
jahrzehnten fest steckt ist eine kunst
miserables wirtschafts und sozialpolitik
eine politik die es den rahmen nicht
erlaubt hat sein enormes potenzial
auszuschöpfen und ja ich habe potenzial
gesagt denn das land der perser verfügt
eigentlich über viele der notwendigen
grundlagen um ein wohlhabendes und
fortschrittliches land zu werden
und ja ihr seht gerade visual politik
und nein wir haben nicht den verstand
verloren
möchtet ihr also erfahren was genau er
damit meinen seid ihr gespannt darauf
die andere seite des iran zu entdecken
über die nie gesprochen wird gut könnte
es gut zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine rarität im nahen osten
der iran ist ein land das im nahen osten
liegt und von ländern umgeben ist die
sich stark von ihm unterscheiden auf der
einen seite gibt es die türkei eine
aufstrebende sunnitische macht die sich
zu einer regionalen führungsmacht
entwickelt und auf der anderen seite
gibt es länder wie den irak afghanistan
und pakistan die nicht gerade die
stabilsten und sichersten orte der welt
der iran ist auch die größte schiitische
macht in der islamischen welt und das
ist wichtig da die beiden hauptzeugen
des islams zu nehmen und schiiten seit
jahrhunderten zerstritten sind wie auch
vorstellen könnte einfluss diese
tatsache die beziehungen des iran zu
vielen seiner nachbarn auf sehr starke
weise aber mal langsam
denn wir reden hier immer noch über die
staatlichen ebenen auf der
gesellschaftlichen ebene gibt es einen
anderen eher an ein land das vollkommen
anders ist als das was die meisten leute
im westen im kopf haben ein land der
krassen gegensätze zwischen staatsmacht
und gesellschaft
[Musik]
klar alle wissen dass die islamische
republik iran ein totalitäres regime
lässt in welchen homosexuell und frauen
die außerehelichen sex hatten zu tode
verurteilt werden
im gegensatz dazu ist jedoch das
iranische volk eine grundsätzliche
säkuläre und relativ moderne
gesellschaft ein himmelweiter
unterschied zu ländern wie zum beispiel
saudi arabien und nicht nur das es ist
auch eine ziemlich gut gebildete
gesellschaft mit zugang zu relativ guten
schulen und einen alphabetisierungs graz
der weit über den durchschnitt der
region liegt 90 prozent der erwachsenen
können lesen und schreiben verglichen
mit 80 prozent im regionalen schnitt
aber das ist nicht das auffälligste am
iranischen bildungsniveau das
erstaunlichste ist dass der prozentsatz
der bevölkerung mit
universitätsabschluss im vergleich zur
tatsächlichen wirtschaftskraft des
landes überraschend hoch ist
wo ich eine vorstellung zu geben jedes
jahr studieren etwa 45 millionen iraner
an einer universität fast acht prozent
der gesamten erwachsenen bevölkerung ein
prozess der dem der am meisten
entwickelten länder der erde entspricht
und ich bin mir sicher dass ich an
dieser stelle viele von euch die frage
stellen wie so was überhaupt möglich ist
in einer islamischen republik in der
frauen auf krasse weise diskriminiert
werden
nun in diesem speziellen fall und ich
bestehe darauf dass es wirklich nur um
den bereich der bildung geht ist dies
nur ein stereotyp tatsächlich legen ihre
anschluss frauen und männer bei den
studierendenzahlen gleich auf die frauen
haben sogar schon einen leichten
vorsprung die probleme zeigen sich aber
sobald sie dann auch arbeiten wollen
denn die beschäftigungsquote von frauen
mit hochschulabschluss ist aufgrund
einer vielzahl diskriminierender gesetze
und vorschriften viel niedriger als die
von männern um euch eine vorstellung zu
geben
der internationale währungsfonds schätzt
dass das bruttoinlandsprodukt des landes
und mehr als 40 prozent steigen würde
denn iranischer frauen auf dem gleichen
niveau wirtschaftlich aktiv wären wie
männer und in ähnlicher weise ist der
iran auch eines der länder mit der
höchsten rate an hochqualifizierten
arbeitslos zwischen der hohen zahl an
hochschulabsolventen und ihrem
tatsächlichen bedarf in der wirtschaft
klappt nämlich eine gigantische lücke
denn dieser bedarf wird durch die
enormen wirtschaftlichen probleme und
fehlenden investitionen massiv gedämpft
je nachdem ob wir feststellen oder
verein statistiken glauben schenken
schaffen es zwischen 20 prozent rund 45
prozent der mit hochschulabschluss nicht
einen angemessenen job zu sind viele von
ihnen waren daher aus und die stellt
einen weiteren wichtigen faktor da die
opportunitätskosten dieses brain james
belaufen sich laut weltbank auf etwa 50
milliarden dollar pro jahr aber war es
ein moment denn in der iranischen
wirtschaft wimmelt es nur so vor
kuriositäten zum beispiel ist die
iranische wirtschaft im gegensatz zu den
nachbarn am persischen golf gar nicht
mal in besonders hohem maße von
erdöleinnahmen abhängig obwohl das land
doch über die größten erdöl und
erdgasreserven der welt verfügt und auch
ordentlich fördert die situation ist
also anders als in saudi arabien kuwait
wo sobald der ölpreis fällt alle
alarmglocken läuten und sich alle auf
eine neue krise vorbereiten
[Musik]
damit gilt die iranische wirtschaft im
gegensatz zum regionalen trend als stark
diversifizierte volkswirtschaft zum
beispiel macht der sektor noch 18
prozent des bip des landes aus
verglichen mit den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten wo er bei etwa 30
prozent liegt oder saudi arabien wo er
42 prozent der wirtschaft ausmacht und
das wurde ihre an schätzungsweise neun
prozent der weltweiten erdölreserven und
16 prozent der welt erdgasreserven sein
eigen nennt auch wenn wir uns die
gesamte struktur der iranischen
wirtschaft ansehen ändert sich viel mehr
der eines industrielandes als ihr
vielleicht gedacht habt so macht der
dienstleistungssektor wird uns 40
prozent des bip aus und rechnen die
finanz branche hinzu steigt diese zahl
sogar auf 51 prozent
ein weiteres beispiel ist die
landwirtschaft die über acht prozent der
wirtschaft ausmacht was war viel höher
ist als in einem ermittelten land üblich
aber auf dem niveau von ländern in einem
fortgeschrittenen entwicklungsstadium
und was viele von euch wahrscheinlich
auch nicht wissen dass die tatsache dass
der iran den erdöl und erdgas auch sehr
sehr reich an mineralien und kerzen ist
tatsächlich verfügt das land über eine
der weltweit größten reserven an
feldspat verrückt im spirit und eisen
sowie an strategischen rohstoffen wie
kupfer mangan zink chrom und gold es
wird geschätzt dass sich etwas 5 prozent
aller weltweiten metall kasernen in iran
befinden natürlich bleibt das meisten
dieser reserven ungenutzt weil es an
investitionen und kapazitäten mangelt
sie zu fördern
aber nachdem wir diesen punkt erreicht
haben lasst uns mal inhalten und
rekapitulieren
wir befinden uns in einem land das
ungeheuer reich ist an natürlichen
ressourcen in einer privilegierten lade
mit einer diversifizierten wirtschaft
und einer jungen im regionalen vergleich
relativ säkularen und sehr gut
ausgebildeten bevölkerung mit anderen
worten der iran verfügt über fast alle
grundlegenden zutaten die notwendig sind
um zu einem entwickelten land
aufzusteigen ja sogar ein wohlhabendes
land zu werden tja wenn es nicht von
einer despotischen clique beherrscht
würde die ihr eigenes volk unterdrückt
und alles verabscheut was irgendwie nach
westen riecht daher sieht die iranische
realität ganz anders aus als dieser
traum von erfolg und wohlstand
aus diesem grund rangiert der iraner im
pro kopf bip weltweit auf platz 100 auf
eine stufe mit ländern wie jamaika
namibia und trojaner aber halt wie er es
will der verein mit vergessen dass
dieses land von monstern reagiert wird
die unschuldige menschen foltern und
ermorden holocaust und zur staatsdoktrin
erhoben haben und ganz israel am
liebsten mit atombomben auslösen würden
lasst uns doch mal einen moment träumen
mit dem millionen von freiheitsliebenden
ihre adern die in ihrer heimat
unterdrückt werden oder im exil leben
lasst uns darüber nachdenken wie ein
iran mit einem modernen politischen
system aussehen würde wie könnte ein
solches land aus schauen warum läuft
investoren und großen multinationalen
konzerne jedes mal das wasser im munde
zusammen wenn auch nur ein hauch der
hoffnung aufkeimt im iran könnte sich
doch mal etwas zum positiven ändern nun
schauen wir uns das an
[Musik]
das große ungenutzte potenzial
ein beispiel nehmen wir die probleme des
irans bei der nutzung seines potenzials
sehr gut veranschaulichen können ist
erdgas
der iran verfügt über die zweitgrößten
nachgewiesenen erdgasreserven der welt
hinter russland und vor katar
trotzdem beträgt seinen marktanteil an
dem weltweiten erdgas exporten kaum ein
prozent und der vergleich mal einen
blick ins benachbarte katar ein land mit
kommt 300.000 einwohnern dessen fläche
143 mal kleiner ist als die des iran nun
quartal rechnet damit dank seiner
investition in kürzester zeit etwa 50
milliarden dollar pro jahr durch den
verkauf von kohlenwasserstoffen ist
besondere erdgas zu verdienen das allein
entspricht praktisch der gesamten
jährlichen exportleistung des irans also
noch mal ganz langsam zum mitschreiben
das günstige katar wird mit erdgas weil
es so viel verdienen wie der riesige
iran mit all seinen exportgütern
zusammengenommen würden also einen
politisch wirtschaftlichen wandel
hinkriegen und beruhigung investitionen
reduzieren könnten allein die jährlichen
einnahmen aus dem export von erdöl
erdgas und anderen bodenschätzen in
wenigen jahren 250 milliarden pro jahr
übersteigen kannst du schreiben von der
enormen menge an kapital und
investitionen die dann ins land strömen
würden in relativ kurzer zeit vielleicht
nur während eines jahrzehnts könnte der
iran seine exporte im vergleich zum
stand von vor der letzten runde von
us-sanktionen mehr als das vierfache
steigern und das liebe zuschauer ist
noch nicht alles
auch in bezug auf die nutzung
erneuerbarer energien ist dieses land in
einem optimalen zustand nicht nur dass
75 prozent des landes bestens für die
solare stromerzeugung der eignet sondern
auch bei der iran in einem winter liegt
in dem die bild geschwindigkeiten und 40
metern höhe über dem meeresspiegel in
mindestens 25 prozent des landes
durchschnittlich 5 meter pro sekunde
übersteigen was ihn auch in puncto
windenergie zu einem spitzenreiter
machen könnte
mit anderen worten wenn sich das
politische und wirtschaftliche system
ändern würde könnte der iran in einigen
jahren auf die spitzenplätze der größten
energie mächte der welt aufsteigen
der iran hätte ein reichhaltiges angebot
sowohl an fossiler als auch eine sehr
billige erneuerbarer energie und das ist
ein enormer wettbewerbsvorteil geradezu
eine diversifizierte wirtschaft denn
industrie ist sehr sehr energiehungrig
und siehe da hier kommt auch die gut
ausgebildet und sehr sehr junge
bevölkerung 60 prozent der iraner sind
unter 30 jahre alt ins spiel der mit
japan china und europa über altern könnt
ihr das land sondern enormen
demografischen dividende profitieren
mit anderen worten all diese
investitionen würden zum bestmöglichen
demografischen zeitpunkt kommen wenn das
land eine junge gebildete bevölkerung
hat die sich gerne auf neue
geschäftsaktivitäten einlässt und das
erste capital vervielfachen kann und
noch etwas ist eigentlich die besondere
geografische lage des landes aufgefallen
der iran liegt genau in dieser zone
welche den aus asiatischen und
europäischen markt verbindet eine
geostrategische joker kontinenten wert
sowohl für den transit von passagieren
und waren als auch für die produktion
und die lieferung von rohstoffen und
energie
nicht umsonst spielt das land eine
schlüsselrolle in der seitenstraßen
initiative der chinesischen regierung
kurz gesagt jedes land kann wachstum
erreichen das ist klar aber das kuriose
an iran ist dass er bereits über alle
notwendigen zutaten verfügt um eine
erfolgsgeschichte zu werden nun alle bis
auf eine
und vielleicht die wichtigste das
politische und wirtschaftliche system
sobald das mittelalterlichen régina
erdöl als ein für alle mal fällt und der
iran sich der welt öffnet wie es sich
die große mehrheit der iraner ja wünscht
könnte dieses land zu einem
wirtschaftlichen star werden der seine
wirtschaft in relativ wenigen jahren und
das drei bis vierfache vergrößert haben
tatsächlich gibt es nur wenige orte auf
der welt an denen die kosten einer
miserablen regierung und eines
teuflischen politischen systems zu hoch
sind wie im iran einen landespreis alles
hat um ein star zu sein aber dennoch zur
ächtung niedergang und chancenlosigkeit
verdammt ist die fragen die wir uns
stellen können lauten also werden wir
bald echte veränderungen in dem land
sehen das ist das ehemalige persische
reich war werden wir eine
gegenrevolution erleben die den iran auf
den weg zum wirtschaftlichen umbringen
kann kann etwas getan werden um diesen
wandel zu beschleunigen und wo kann ich
ihre aktien kaufen hinterlasst uns eure
antworten dazu bitte in den kommentaren
und was ihr dieses video interessant
findet vergesst bitte nicht erst zweiten
und visual politik zu abonnieren
macht gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]